what's happening you sons of guns we are
going to watch the bad batch today
episode something or another
five four damn hey guys
once you hit that like button if you end
up enjoying our video and
also subscribe and click that
notification bell i want to thank the
few who watch
these videos of ours for the bad batch
you know the deal you get the drill
full-length watch alongs that are all
over on that
website and then on that website you get
the option for
many shows where you get reaction
highlights and watch along
included thanks to pratham jadal for
editing these reaction highlights for us
or your partner i don't know his name
nor do i care to know his name
i care i just call him pratham's friend
please do a good job if you are the one
editing
ship looks like it's struggling we don't
have enough fuel and we are also
entirely out of rations
without the republic to provide us
supplies we'll have to acquire these
necessities on
our own com chatter has our ship's
signature on a wanted list
so we scrambling but i need to land in
order to perform those modifications
by my calculations the closest planet is
pantora well i'm gonna have to i don't
know
pandora like from avatar it
is gonna get to do some sploring after
all
don't worry omega terrible things are
probably gonna happen when you're there
peril danger all of it
beautiful
[Music]
is that a ugg not yes
uh i think so sure looks like one
you fellas here for repairs just a minor
calibration
i think i think i'm correct just need to
scan your ship in
are you sure about that i suppose i
could skip that step
ah that was easy um aren't you uh
forgetting something
you you said you'd skip the step i could
right if some incentive
of the financial variety
i think he means credits
is that sufficient incentive
i've spoken you're greedy danny devito
[Music]
this is raspberry 6 at rose station
i'll make it well worth your while
transmit the coordinates
and make sure they don't leave
me now when voicing her too yeah i'd
know that voice anywhere
you can't sell that explosive it's our
last one
only thing we have worth any money why
attack and i have to do all the repairs
or you get to go
sightseeing sightseeing no no no no
this is a supply run in and out quickly
and quietly and you stick out too much
oh and you don't not dressed like this
uh i think they're going to mistake you
for a droid yeah
[Laughter]
i get why they got an ugnaught character
now because he got fedex chant here it's
all the mandalorian stuff just tying it
up
i know all easter eggs stressing myself
out
staring scanning the frame picking up
every little detail these signature keys
should be embedded below the rear
parallax
inverters just tell me what to rip out
it was the best english please moment
i've seen
hey kid you break it you buy it sorry
i'll buy that droid off you if you're
looking to sell something
how about your droid yes what i was
worried about
he's a military prototype military eh
i'll give you billions of credits give
me a minute we need the credits
once we get the supplies i'll give you
the signal leave
oh no that's fine but not at that price
i am worth more than two thousand right
you are
you're a [ __ ] echo
selling your body for cold or cash
cute creatures merchandise
[Music]
oh hey wait wait
hey
how many children how old is she that's
a good question too
[Music]
omega omega
this is the best trip with the show so
far it's her most consistent character
trait
is wandering off
i'm walking here like a goat
you seem lost i got separated from my
friends
i can help with that we'll find them oh
you're good
playing the mother roll motherly like
roll you know what i meant
we'll finally have some order around
here uh
there's just like r2 and c3po
from star wars only we'd notice that i
i don't think anyone else breakdown
you're not a droid
you're right click i will report his
deception at once
i'll take your complaint dear me
what else
you protocol droids
[Music]
hot hunter hut tracker down hunt
use your skills are you a soldier
not exactly then why do you have a
blaster
to protect myself the galaxy's a
dangerous place to be on your own
yeah it's a good thing i have my friends
aren't you lucky
aren't you lucky omega oh there's one of
my friends now
oh golly out comes the rifle
step away from her why she was helping
me look for you
yes omega and i were getting to know
each other
hmm like this threatening sinister
approach to here
[Applause]
[Music]
omega run
[Music]
there that is the signature key
got it wrecker
i lost omega somebody attacked us
somebody who hardly trained
she's after the kid yeah we'll see about
that
i'll tap into the central security
network there should be enough cameras
in this city to find
there's a bounty out for omega well
she's highly valuable
and unless you have a team of
maintenance droids it's going to be a
while
i can help with that we're going into
the field
what are the odds
[Music]
where do you think you're all going get
back inside
you're not a droid you got me for a
bargain
know your worth my friend
i have eyes on omega she went down into
the maintenance tunnels
she's got company
we're on our way
get to this [ __ ] i'll handle her
dude fennec shannon getting to fight all
these cool characters
oh no no
[Music]
[Music]
i am not programmed to repair or
assemble starships
i give the orders around here i can't
know where that thing is
[Music]
in the lower i do not see wrecker but
omega is hanging from a maintenance
tower in the skyway
hanging for now i suggest you hurry
[Music]
yeah come on what's he gonna do oh
that's weird
he's gonna draw it he's gonna like sit
there
[Music]
you can thank me later this is like your
fault
tuck and roll when you land kid
[Music]
i gotta
this is like that attack of the clones
opening chase
or reminds me of it's not exactly
up taking a dump
space music
she just murdered that man she just
killed that guy poor innocent civilian
was murdered
probably splattered across someone's
window
[Music]
that was terrifying yeah
whoa dang
[Music]
[Music]
not bad hunter
ah cool exploded
i'm missing all the action
thanks for the help boys
they're all yours you heard him i am
back in charge
follow me
we need to go now wrecker pick up the
pace
we don't have all day for a guy
[Laughter]
he's trying
she has to be a bounty hunter a what
someone hired to retrieve targets and
you
appear to be the target we have to find
out who she is and who hired her
cut her open
see what makes her tick no wait
i tried to stop them
if they come back you know how to
contact me
the target got away but i'll find her
is she talking to moff
gideon
probably huh or is that tarkin
well i remember she didn't she they say
she
once worked for her i remember all she's
experiencing star wars she's next
imperial
so this would be at least during the
early stages of her work with the empire
so
i don't know where gideon's at in this
whole thing but it could be
him it could be tarkin could be i think
he just
started opening
los poyos or manos yeah at this point in
the show yeah yeah yeah in fact there's
a deleted scene of this episode where
his first location they stopped
in that makeshift a lot more sense yeah
definitely
got it origins so she was definitely
hired
definitely by boba fett yes
uh-huh this is the the lead-in to the
book of boba fett
got it no i i got it yeah i got it
yeah she's darth vader
it's mike time because this is where
we're just talking
just talking so that way you could hear
the sultry sounds of john's voice
john yeah what did you think of the
episode of
the mandalorian prequel phenix and
origins kill
which i mean they would all those things
would probably match together pretty
well i couldn't imagine the hundred
hundred people in this world you know
it took me a second to realize it was an
ugg not because i was like
i've only seen an ugnon in live action
and
i think that's one right there
if not it's it's it's another similarly
towed like
short squat creature what'd you think of
the episode
i thought it was really fun and
thrilling i mean oh my god john you like
everything
i thought this episode sucked already it
was a terrible
episode way too much action
uh i could have just used some senate
hearings or something like that you know
um no i mean there
are some ways in which this episode
certainly kind of reminds me of a
mandalorian-esque scenario but uh yeah i
thought it was really fun i thought the
different bits that they
uh brought up and had to work with were
a lot of fun
between you know everything with fenik
shand and omega
uh you know it's a bit tropish the way
that omega always wanders off
and gets into some kind of trouble but
also you know it's it's part of the
familiar sort of
canon of storytelling that star wars
also borrows from so i'm okay with that
um but yeah i just thought it made for a
lot of fun action and the way that they
managed to divide the team up with these
different tasks uh especially with echo
doing the whole like posing as a droid
thing made for some
fun to undercut you know the more
intense aspects of the episode
so uh overall i had much
fun again john you are not doing a solo
discussion you just talk about way too
you hit too many points
at once you know we gotta share some
things to dive into
together what did i think of the episode
i thought the action was good let's
start there you know
like hey it was a really good episode
some awesome things i had some issues
with some things were familiar but yeah
overall
it's just a bottom line consensus you
don't just have to go into
everything you know what i mean yeah you
went into every detail
every single one you broke down this
whole episode
we can do anything else today my
presence is now right
necessary click the like button shout
out
for patreon of the day shouting
now you you didn't talk on everything i
agree though
uh yes i think that it was
a good episode it was exciting like i
i'm a sucker for a good chase scene you
know
and it did remind me of the opening of
attack of the clones
when jedi are hunting down
bounty hunter and literally the city and
the lighting and all that
does look very similar to
uh it's not the same planet actually you
know what
i don't know no it's not no this is a
new planet
we haven't seen this i don't think we've
seen this planet before
um so no it's it's a different planet
but uh overall you know like seeing
frenetic shanna that's probably like the
biggest
the coolest appreciation for it is you
know like when fennec shan first showed
up in mandalorian
she got her ass kicked yes you know not
right away
but it felt like ah missed opportunity
and then bam she comes back in season
two and she's great and now she's
gonna be starring alongside uh tamora
morrison
in the book of boba fett and i'm sure
we're gonna see even
more badassery from her and to see the
early stages of her because now she's
like
more of a hero presence and here they
made her full-on bounty hunter the same
way how when she was introduced to
mandalorian
in this villainous aspect you bring her
back here
uh where you see her just as like a
sort of a ruthless bounty hunter and one
was like whooping all kinds of ass
throughout like they had to
do a lot of work to get the upper hand
on her and to get omega back you know
and it took several people well two but
it still took a a group effort and
a lot of chasing around and everything
so that was really rewarding to see that
side of her because she is intimidating
and i love how
like when she does go toe-to-toe with
hunter a big part of me was like please
don't get your ass
kicked fenik shan please don't and then
bam she dits the upper hand same thing
with
wrecker uh instantly takes him out it's
awesome
and i don't feel like we got like a go i
feel like one might argue
with me on the moment where she catches
omega and is like
thank me later like i let you live or i
saved your life but i'm like
well this chase wouldn't be happening if
it wasn't for you yeah
you were just they let her really embody
the
in my perspective they let her really
embody just being a villain
in this episode i and i thought that's
really cool to get a character who
we've grown to really be fond of post
mandalorian season two
and to and then knowing that we're going
to get her as one of the main characters
in an upcoming live-action
spin-off show to really just hone in on
her as an antagonist in this episode i
think is a pretty cool move
yeah yeah and it speaks to the sort of
overall longevity of
the franchise and how this does john and
sprawling that franchises
uh and maybe this experience will
shed some light on her behavior
in the mandalorian when coming across
danjarin and the child
that's fair these are all fair points
so the other thing i really enjoyed too
was um
uh echo being a prostitute you know of
course
yeah pouring his body out for the sake
of the mission
and demanding hey but but my man's was
on it he was like you know what i'm not
worth
2 000 measly credits all right you pay
what i'm worth
yeah he gets lucky with being stuck with
all the maintenance droids
i mean it's like a very it like it is
very convenient and
we get the credits and we get the droids
we get everything like
everything if we had sold that bomb
this episode would have turned out
entirely differently and we all might
have died
a lot of things really kind of worked in
their favor other than the whole fennec
champ thing showing up
um yeah you know like it seems like they
keep handing off
uh tick uh to do repairs
right that's right you know anyone
tracking them to figure out what sort of
mcguffin we need to fix this time
yeah uh you know i really i like
you see i'm reminded of like in the
clone wars
when you had the first two episodes with
the bad batch i loved
tech really in the field i love like
when he's there he's having to get them
through doors and [ __ ] like i really
love that stuff
and i i want to see more of that from
tech because right now they keep like
working on the ship yeah you know tech
is like a relief character one of the
relief characters right now is sort of
like when you're with him you're in a
more safe environment
yeah exactly and i like them all but
yeah i want to see i want to get more of
that
in there uh the relationship with the
record omega keeps crying
i did find it if i'm being honest
it's one of those things you can have
multiple emotions about one thing
despite the black and white thinking
that is often reflected in comment boxes
i do think that i
completely get wise a character like
omega
who everything is foreign to her like so
foreign to her
she's a child still and she's very much
fascinated by things that she would be
like ooh
cool and be like a magnet you know
yeah interesting right and then be uh
gullible to people you know who are
behaving
uh suspiciously
dark and mysterious and be like your new
friend
come with me to help find your friends
and we're just going to keep walking
straight away from the way that you can
join the game
uh i get it i do uh it it doesn't also
mean that i don't find this thing it's
becoming a little bit
repetitive and at times a little
annoying
it's a hunter to be like where's omega
and how do you find
me yeah it becomes a little bit um
it's or four episodes in i'm already
like come on
come on makeup it's the kid in her four
big brother's show sorry
start questioning some [ __ ] would you
yeah uh
but i i still love the mystery as to who
she
is i mean she was prob the person who
the actual bounty hunter who uh i mean
the actual person who probably hired
fennic shand
is most likely um the prime minister of
uh camino um
maximizing their marketing potential
here is perfect
i that's it's amazing with star wars
what i
what i remember i remembered ugg not but
then when it came to the name of the ugg
not
queal i was like is it kill you or a
queen
in my mind just call it at the moment
uh yeah that and i don't remember
something with shyamalan
is that guy's name is also what is the
prime minister's name
from from uh from kamino hold on
from rush hour they're all in a second i
got a list of names
right llama sue we were close you see
how i
got ts yes i got i see how you got
oh come on yeah it's kind of similar
certainly if you just flip the names
around they would kind of sound a little
similar yeah
yeah i'm just saying i'm not a hundred
percent that's an easter egg
that's an easter egg for you guys right
there um
but yeah you know i still enjoy this
show it's pretty rad yeah and i thought
the
the action was a delight to watch
undoubtedly that was really cool fight
scenes for sure
the chances really well visualized
pretty soon that ship is they're going
to be outside in space suits just
pushing that ship a little bit
so that no one can detect us we need to
turn the ship off
but i think the last two yeah i think
the last two
episodes ended with uh started
with having the ship in um hyperspace
hyperspeed hyperdrive
warp speed warp speed
[Laughter]
yeah is there any other big jumble in my
brain
it's all sci-fi so it it ended the spike
start it started there and then here it
starts off and it's just like
having a hard time getting to a planet
you know yeah yeah so
soon that ship is going to break down
it's going to be terrible it's getting
to
we need to get some a couple other
storytelling dynamics and and yeah
perhaps a little more uh at least
acknowledgement of the dangers of the
world around from a makeup
very true yeah all right guys so what
did you guys think of the bad batch
episode four what's this called
crossroads cornered i think cornered
yeah i think you're right about it there
are a lot of corners in this episode
what you remember and what i remember
were like that's we're like yin and yang
we complete each other
yeah we're like milk and
peanut butter peanut butter and milk
bananas and bacon and banana and bacon
and on an elvis sandwich
with rye bread dry oh the sourdough
banana prep pastrami cottage cheese
sandwich
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button
say hi to your mother for me last but
not least
aaron myers a new patron
over at our patreon who qualifies for
the patron of the day
shout out and i sent him a message
saying like anything specific you'd like
us to mention in your shout out
and he said just mercilessly make
fun of me and in the past
i would have but
wow it's actually gotten this guy
a hot water before yes so
aaron as much as i'm getting your
approval
i'm gonna tell you right now i'm not
gonna do that
for safety precautions he does say that
it helps that he has a full-size
green lantern symbol tattooed on his
chest that looks like it was done
by a cross between a four-year-old with
a current day
michael j fox he's making fun of
you could have just said a person with
parkinson's yes any
aaron thank you so much for getting us
canceled and you're one shout out alone
um i really do appreciate you being here
one of my closest friends is a guy named
aaron
uh he's that tall handsome black
gentleman that you might have seen
and are invincible reactions why'd you
mention black
i just thought it'd be easier for you
guys to remember to narrow it down
because he's the most recent black guy
to come on the channel
it wasn't about the fact that he's you
know
aaron congratulations on canceling us i
really appreciate it we will
we will make fun of you for reals the
next time you're you're a [ __ ]
what did i i'm sorry i mean you're
you're michael myers is a
is a is a good character
because you got aaron alexander and then
i did his last name
your your tattoo sucks i want you to
[Music]
leave